The 2018 Winter Games in Pyeongchang will leave a unique...
...and lasting legacy for generations to come.
Every Games does.
But ours will be a legacy beyond bricks and mortar.
A legacy beyond potential world records and gold medals.
Ours is a legacy that creates opportunity and potential for young people,...
...wherever they may be and for whatever they may dream.
Today is one of the most important days in the lives of every member of our team.
Although I will admit, the memory of this day will be a lot sweeter if you choose Pyeongchang.
It is an honor to represent our country.
But perhaps even more poignant,...
...it is an honor to have the chance...
...to impact the millions of young people in the future.
That is something that only the Olympic movement can provide to us.
And that is something that only Pyeongchang 2018 can provide to you today.
We know that whatever decision you make today will be a historic one.
Uniquely, Pyeongchang 2018 offers you both a historic choice...
...and a historic chance to bring the Winter Games to Korea for the first time...
...and back to Asia for only the third time.
And in doing so, help us to deliver the potential, the promise,...
...and yes, the hope of Pyeongchang 2018 to millions of new hearts and minds around the world.
Thank you very much for your attention this afternoon...
... and for the honor of participating in this campaign for the 2018 Winter Games.
And now, in our last film, several of our Dream program children will share with you,...
...perhaps better than anyone can, what "new horizons" truly means.